it looks like someone new has decided to
dive into the world of rapture as
netflix recently announced an upcoming
film adaptation of the seminal game
bioshock to release sometime in the near
future if that sounds all too familiar
that's because it should since
bioshock's groundbreaking release in
2007 studios have been trying to bring
that same success to the big screen
but sadly it's never came to be until
possibly now as it appears that netflix
is trying to choose the impossible but i
am jesse earle and i am here to ask you
a question
what do we want in a bioshock movie a
movie where an artist would not fear the
censor where a streaming service would
not be bound by
petty morality where the great would not
be constrained by the small
and with the sweat of your brow bioshock
can become your movie as well
uh sorry i got a little bit carried away
there anyways would you kindly join me
as we briefly go over the failed history
of the bioshock film franchise and then
go over what we would want to see in
netflix's upcoming adaptation
bioshock is hands down one of the most
iconic series in gaming released as the
spiritual successor to the classic
system shock 2 bioshock helmed by ken
levine rocked the entire medium with its
incredible art direction unique
upgradeable plasmid mechanic deep
environmental storytelling rich
characters and political themes that all
work together to tell one of the most
thought-provoking stories in gaming that
all culminated in one of the most
mind-bending twists in modern memory
bioshock was so beloved that it became
the go-to example for gamers to point at
to argue that yes indeed games were art
the burden of the artist is to
capture
which was still an ongoing debate at the
time with mainstream opinion being that
video games are all just murder
blackjack and hookers but if you have a
kid uh let's say you've got a video game
uh and it involves maiming raping
murdering dismembering which to be fair
a predominant amount of them were but
you know artistic blackjack and hookers
cj a player tonight bioshock was set in
the underwater city of rapture built by
industrial capitalist andrew ryan in
order to create a place where the best
of society i.e the rich pompous and
privileged could escape the
horrid anchor that was society in the
petty rabble below and build a grander
city where they wouldn't be subject to
things like you know
ethics where the scientists would not be
bound by petty morality where the great
would not be constrained by the small
which quickly descended into civil war
with its inhabitants addicted to genetic
tampering serums you know as you do as
jack you enter the city after a plane
crash and are forced to deal with the
denizens of this dystopia with the
franchise's runaway success and intense
visual style and storytelling it's by no
means a shock that hollywood attempted
to try to capitalize on the success with
a big budget adaptation take two
announced a partnership with universal
studios to produce a film directed by
gore verbinski who was fresh off his
success with the first three pirates of
the caribbean films however the film was
put on ice in 2010 due to its ballooning
budget in almost necessity given the
series unique setting and art direction
i like to think it's sadly because they
decided not to shop at the circus of
values
sorry i had to do it that sound has been
in my head since 2007. verbinski
eventually dropped out as director to
hell murango but he continued to fight
as producer for the film to be given an
r rating which left many studios
hesitant to jump onto the project given
the typically low box offers return for
such r-rated films like with the
disappointing performance of zack
snyder's watchman eventually verbinski
and bioshock created ken levine
abandoned the project with levine
stating i don't need a compromise how
many times in life do you not need to
compromise definitely channeling his
inner andrew ryan there however while
the film was cancelled much of
rubinski's visual work got incorporated
into his next project a cure for
wellness starring the green goblin
himself dane dehaan while the film was
set in a mental hospital it surprisingly
retains some of the same distinctive
look and themes of choice and control
found in the original game and as
someone who saw the film in theaters i
actually think it's not that bad think
of it kind of like bioshock meet shutter
island it's by no means fantastic but
it's also not as horrid as its critical
reception would have you believe though
it does culminate in a very video game
like boss fight which is
weird
apparently even bioshock inspired
projects can't have a satisfying final
boss but that brings us to today with
netflix which has had strong success
with video game adaptations in the tv
world with the likes of arcane
castlevania cuphead and the game and
novel inspired the witcher has decided
to have a go at bioshock so that brings
us back to that big question if netflix
is going to use the sweat of its brow to
make a new bioshock movie what do we
want to see in it
number one political themes no says the
man in washington it belongs to the poor
no says the man in the vatican it
belongs to god
no says the man in moscow
it belongs to everyone
now personally i love thoughtful
political themes in all of my art but
even the most ardent of folks who yell
about keep politics out of my gaming
have got to admit that bioshock
basically requires a strong political
viewpoint the original bioshock directly
confronted writer anne rand's philosophy
of objectivism and her arguments that
complete self-interest is morally
correct altruism is actually harmful and
that unfettered capitalism is the best
system apparently yeah uh rand had
ideas let's just say and bioshock
doesn't make its deconstruction of these
ideas subtle with direct references to
rand's work like the fountainhead and
atlas shrugged littered throughout
rapture right down to andrew ryan's name
directly alluding to rand herself even
more so the other games in the series
continued these strong political themes
with bioshock 2 providing a dissection
of concepts of collectivism through karl
marx in stark contrast to rand's
individualism showcasing the franchise's
willingness to engage with the
complexity and greatness of both sides
of these ideologies
yet even more directly and
controversially bioshock infinite itself
confronted how intertwined ideals of
american exceptionalism white supremacy
and nationalism also intermix with
concepts of individualism versus
collectivism in the united states so
yeah bioshock has never been exactly uh
apolitical and so netflix's adaptation
would be doomed from the start if it
tried to provide a more tepid
interpretation of the game's themes
while it shouldn't preach to the viewer
neither should it be afraid to dive into
the moral complexity of the franchise's
is what they politics brothers
to keep you so hungry you can't speak
but to me
number two a revamped story all that
being said while the themes of bioshock
should remain true to its political
roots the actual plot and story needs to
be changed to suit the medium one of
bioshock's greatest contributions to
gaming was its famous twist revealed in
the game's final act a man who chooses
a slave obeys
and while i won't spoil the specifics
here the important thing to note with
that twist is that it only works because
it's in a video game the game uses a
meta commentary of how perception of
player agency is actually being
manipulated and guided in order to
reflect back upon its ideas of how no
one really has agency under objectivist
and capitalist systems seen in the rest
of the world of rapture but that only
works because you the player have been
playing the game and felt like you were
making choices in the game story when
you actually weren't and this will most
likely be the biggest hurdle for the
filmmakers to tackle because if they
simply try to translate the twist from
the game one to one it won't be as close
to as powerful as it was in its original
context due to the shift from a more
active medium to a passive one like film
as a result it might be better for the
movies to focus on a different aspect or
even completely new part of the bioshock
story perhaps seeing the fall of rapture
itself might be a stronger narrative to
follow one which will better fit a
movie's ability to fully control an
audience's viewing experience
number three an artist's vision
get them out of here
there shall be no failure on my canvas
ken levine is a controversial figure in
the gaming world due to allegations of
him potentially fostering a toxic
workplace culture that needs to be
addressed and confronted it is
unquestionable that the original
bioshock game did have a unique creative
vision in fact it's actually an
interesting connection to make between
how the original game questions
individualism with how often bioshock's
unique world gets highlighted only
through the lens of one creator like
levine despite it being the work of
hundreds of developers working together
similarly though that means that any
bioshock movie itself should have a
strong creative vision behind it many of
netflix's films sometimes tend to have
that feeling that they were made by an
algorithm rather than an actual strong
creative impulse with the studio seeming
to worry more about what's marketable
rather than what's interesting to watch
which would go against the entire ethos
of a bioshock story as a result whoever
steps into the director's chair should
have a strong voice in the film's final
creative vision yet one which can work
collaboratively with a team of
individuals to make something truly
amazing like the best directors do
number four an armand shimmerman cameo
okay this may be just the trekkie in me
but one of the best parts of the
original bioshock game is actor armin
shimmerman's excellent voiceover work as
andrew ryan i am andrew ryan
and i'm here to ask you a question
is a man not entitled to the sweat of
his
famous for bringing the capitalist
ferengi bartender with a heart of gold
quark to life in star trek deep space
nine but you know what's really
frightening
if you drink enough of it
you begin to like it
it's insidious
just like the federation
it would be awesome for the movie to pay
homage to the man in the lighthouse with
a small cameo similar to nolan north's
brief appearance in the recent uncharted
film
number five strong physical art
direction this kind of goes without
saying but easily the most stand out
part of every single bioshock game is
its unique sense of place whether it's
rapture's underwater high society style
or the steampunk city in the sky setting
of colombia bioshock has always evoked
its setting through strong art direction
and environmental storytelling something
that should transfer over to any film
adaptation we should truly feel like
rapture or wherever the movie is set is
a real place which would require the
movie's effects being as practical as
possible while certainly an underwater
city would require a heavy amount of cgi
to pull off it would ultimately be
disappointing for the film to feel like
it was made completely in a green screen
studio
somewhere number six big daddies
speaking of practical effects though
what the film adaptation will most
definitely need is some big daddies like
the biggest of daddies because they're
the game's most iconic element and they
need to be
scary given their popularity it would be
easy to make the big daddies feel
underwhelming so it's up to the film to
remind us why they were so iconic in the
first place a big daddy needs to have a
sense of heft presence and threat to
them and we should feel that these guys
are not something to be messed with if
done right big daddies could become just
as iconic on the big screen as they are
in the video game world
meaning that they also need to have a
creepy little sister to accompany them
as well
number seven a mind-blowing experience
while i spoke earlier about the need for
bioshock to eschew just copy-pasting the
game's final twist it would also be a
missed opportunity if the game didn't
take a chance to really mess with our
minds a bit each entry in the bioshock
series has had a truly mindful moment
one that left us reeling with its
potential interpretations as well as
scratching our heads trying to figure
out what it all means it's honestly just
part of the bioshock brand at this point
so while it may be a hard lift and ask
for the movie to both try something new
and deliver a mind-blowing moment it
wouldn't really feel like bioshock if it
didn't manage to pull it off i never
find that as satisfying as i imagined
chin up there's always next time i
suppose there is
number eight connections to the games
now this final entry may be my most
controversial opinion and one i could be
talked out of but i think that a
bioshock movie should actually be in
canon with the games themselves
many video game adaptations today have
actively distanced themselves from the
universe of the games for example the
upcoming paramount plus halo series is
set in a totally new timeline from the
games and the recent uncharted movie
seems to have done the same being a sort
of prequel reboot hybrid of the
franchise's most iconic story moments in
fact the one time where a video game
movie was actually set in the same
universe of the games was 2016's
assassin's creed movie starring michael
fassbender and
it didn't go over super well though i
will say it's by no means a great movie
but i will actually fight for the 18th
century scenes from that movie they're
actually pretty awesome in a great
translation of the assassin's creed
games to movies regardless though one of
the joys of the bioshock universe and by
the way big big spoilers here so skip
ahead a few seconds if you don't want
any spoilers for the bioshock franchise
is that it's actually multiple universes
all any bioshock story requires is a
lighthouse a man and a city outside of
that the worlds are your oyster and i
think the movie will have a cool
opportunity to put itself in direct
conversation with the games while i
don't necessarily need the movie to
somehow cross over with the events of
the games it would be cool to see brief
nods to the interconnected nature of the
bioshock franchise
and that is my list for everything that
i want in a bioshock movie besides
sander cohen i also want sander cohen in
a bioshock movie because that man is
simply wonderful
there's no room in rapture anymore
for the artist
oh and the lutest twins too they're also
great some of my favorite characters in
all of gaming ah man i there are so many
things that i want in this movie anyways
i hope you see what i mean because
regardless until the movie arrives we'll
have to keep debating what we want in it
so i'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below do you agree with my list
or do you think that i don't have the
vision of a true autist and don't forget
to like and subscribe to stay up to date
on all the news you need to know right
here on gamespot
[Music]
you